Joaquin Phoenix may play a man with an uncontrollable
cackle in director Todd Phillips' Joker, but
he certainly wasn't laughing in an interview
about the dark and gritty comic book movie.
Phoenix, who stars as failed comedian Arthur
Fleck in the Joker origin story film releasing
on October 4, sat down for an interview with
The Telegraph's Robbie Collin.
During the conversation, Collin asked Phoenix
if he was worried that his performance might
inspire real world copycat killers.
The question apparently took Phoenix by surprise,
causing the actor to briefly walk out of the
interview.
Collin described what happened:
"Unlike Heath Ledger's inscrutable take on
the character in 2008's The Dark Knight, Phoenix's
Arthur Fleck, a failed comedian who still
lives with his elderly mother, is the horribly
familiar enemy within.
If the film hadn't been set in the '80s he
could easily be the latest online message-board
extremist to take his grievances murderously
viral.
Yet Phoenix doesn't seem to have considered
this kind of question at all.
So when I put it to him aren't you worried
that this film might perversely end up inspiring
exactly the kind of people it's about, with
potentially tragic results?
his fight-or-flight response kicks in."
Phoenix reportedly replied,
"Why?
Why would you?
No… no."
According to Collin, Phoenix then stood up,
shook his hand, and left the interview.
"all I have are negative thoughts."
Roughly an hour later largely spent talking
with Warner Bros.' PR team Phoenix returned
to finish the interview.
The actor explained that he left because he
had never considered the possibility, and
needed time to try and figure out an appropriate
response.
But the interview concluded without Phoenix
answering the question.
And it's a question that many critics are
already asking.
Though most reviewers gave Joker high marks
after its worldwide debut at the Venice International
Film Festival on August 31, 2019, more than
one also suggested that the film may send
a dangerous message and give viewers the wrong
idea about avenging their own personal grievances.
Vanity Fair critic Richard Lawson wondered
in his review of Joker whether the film, quote,
"may be irresponsible propaganda for the very
men it pathologizes."
Stephanie Zacharek at Time felt that Arthur
Fleck comes across uncomfortably similar to
some of the most violent, dangerous people
who have inflicted incredible harm to people,
particularly in America.
She wrote in part,
"All of Arthur's travails are leading up to
a series of 'See what you made me do?'
brutalities, most of which happen while he's
dressed up in his clown suit.
Violence makes him feel more in control, less
pathetic.
Killing [...] empowers him [...] The movie
lionizes and glamorizes Arthur even as it
shakes its head, faux-sorrowfully, over his
violent behavior."
Collin himself tweeted after watching Joker
at the Venice Film Festival that he thinks
the movie is good, but he's, quote, "worried
someone's going to get killed" because of
it.
He stated in his full review, published by
The Telegraph,
"This is a film that is going to stir up trouble
in the consciences of everyone who watches
it, and almost certainly in the outside world
as well."
"When I was a little boy and told people I
was going to be a comedian, everyone laughed
at me.
Well, no one's laughing now!"
Other critics, though, have defended the film.
The Outline's Alex Nichols argued that the
idea of Joker's violence potentially resulting
in real-life tragedies, quote, "rests entirely
on the assumption that violent media breeds
violent behavior."
Stephen Galloway of The Hollywood Reporter
agreed, arguing that the only people who would
be inspired to violence are people predisposed
to it already.
He said there's
"[no] evidence to show that a criminal even
one who imitates something on film wouldn't
have done something equally abominable at
another time."
It seems this type of complexity and ambiguity
may have been one of the biggest reasons why
Phoenix signed on for Joker in the first place.
As the actor told Collin after coming back
for the interview, he liked that Arthur Fleck
as a character, quote, "pos[ed] questions
with no easy answers."
Decide how you feel about Joker when the film
opens in theaters on October 4.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.